[音楽]
th
いつでも楽しく
残せるといいですよねいつでも自分のしたいことがはっきり分かってて
それを叶えるため行動に移せたらいいんでしょうけどなかなかそうはいかなくて目標に
向かって進んでいくうちに今の今自分が何をしたいのかわからなくなったり
あるいは売り言葉に買い言葉みたいなやり取りをしちゃって
仲が悪くなってしまったり
また本当に自分がしたいことをありに遠慮して
できなかったり
まあ確かに自分のしたいことを望みが叶った方がいいんですけど
本当にそれが自分の望みなのか
一度改めてちょっと落ち着いて
を確認する時間っていうのも必要でしょう
自分がいま何を祈っているのか
それをしましょうという話では今日はなくて自分はいつも何かを祈ってるんですよって
いうことを知っておくといいんだよっていう話をします
マイ法って聞くとこういう格好もしてますし
特別な場所で特別な相手にぽく別なジェスチャーで行う特別なことだと
思うかも知れませんだけどそれは僕らの日常の中の小さな望みや期待をしっかり伝える
ために意識化したもので
そもそもは僕らの日常は小さな望み
小さな祈りでできている例えば朝起きて延期予報
見てホッとして
それぞれの目的のために出かけてそして会いたかった人に会って楽しく過ごして
欲しかった物を買いに行って
家族に会いたくなって
家に帰って
待ち望んでたご飯を食べて
そして明日のためにまたエブリンつく
僕らの日常はそういう小さな望み
したいことの積み重ねでいわば僕らは日々
祈り続けながら暮らしているを言えると思いますそれを知ってると少し楽しくなれるよ
っていう話なんですけど
まあある知り合いの
農家のご夫婦がいて楽しそうなんですね
子供のときから
お祈りの習慣があるご夫婦で
まあその都度自分が今何がしたいのか自分が何を祈っているのか
確認
してるんですねそういう習慣があるだから自分の祈りをいつも分かっている
加えてそういう習慣があるので自分がいつも何かを祈っていることを分かっている自分
にはしたいことがあってそれを叶えようとしていることを分かっている
つまり時はいつも前を向いているということをよくわかっているだか
らいつも楽しそうですまあ僕らのようなあの仕事というか格好の人間は我々は生かされ
ているとよく言いますよね
まあ確かにそれはそうかもしれないだけど今日話したいのは我々が生かされている
けれども我々は自分で生きている
どんなに苦しい時も大変な時も何もしたくない
思っている時もあるいはこのままじゃダメなんだけどなぁって何もできないでいるとき
もそれでも僕らの目は前を向いていて
その時見ている方向それが自分にとっての前で
そしていつだってここには
したいことつまり祈りが沸き起こってきていてそれをいつだって僕ら叶えようとついし
ちゃってる
いつも前を向いている前向きが僕らの本性なんだよということを知っておくと
ちょっとだけまあ元気になって
今の日曜は少し楽しくなって
まあ大丈夫かなってこう思えるようになるかなと思います
最後に今日は僕が昔から好きな言葉をみなさんに贈りたいなぁと思うんですけど
日本人が昔よく行ってた言葉です今生きている人たちはひょっとしたら忘れててでも今
聞けば新鮮な海を感じるかもしれない
残り物には福があるいますよね
まあそう焦らずに自分のペースで一方
やっていけば
と楽しいことが待っていると思いますだからまあ焦らずに大丈夫です一緒にやっていき
ましょう
ありがとうございました
[音楽]